traveling right now stephen i'm in los
angeles and i'm working and i'm doing
press and so
i've just been everywhere and kobit is
still happening in toronto that's where
i spend most of my time
and everything is still locked down so
i've yet to get a new laptop i've yet to
get new airpods the airpods are actually
from production so
i'm just a hot mess technically all good
though
i'm also in los angeles and i'm going to
tell you something that i've learned
over the last
i'd say year or two there are these
things
called websites and they sell
technological products
like computers and other things
in fact i even just bought an iphone for
the first time last night
on a on a website called apple
that's funny i'm gonna be honest man i'm
gonna be honest with you
i have never bought anything online in
my entire life
i've never done that before in my entire
life yeah man i'm
i'm an old-school person in the center
like to go to the malls but that being
said
i hear you and noted and definitely i
gotta go online and use the thing called
the internet and go on the site called
apple and make my orders how have you
made it this far without ordering
anything online
reading a lot of books man that's it is
reading a lot of books
a lot of books watching a lot of movies
you don't need you don't need anything
online for those and you order pizza
pizza you just call a pizza comes to the
house and we chill i like mankind
a beautiful mankind you know so i gotta
hang out there that's it
totally so uh first of all nice to talk
to you again thanks for doing this this
morning um
since we have a little bit more time i
have a few different questions that i
can ask
which i ask a lot of people um when i
have more than four minutes
or five minutes um uh and these first
two questions i ask of everyone during
the pandemic
um what tv series would you love to
guest star on oh that's a great question
and i enjoyed talking to you last time
that's why i woke up this morning for
this i really had a good time with you
so thank you um which tv series i'd want
to guest star on
yeah i think i think the the the
topical answer should be bridgerton
because it's the most hottest show on
television but i'm not going to
i don't want to get started no
disrespect to shout out anybody on that
show it's just
one girl watching that show she loves
that show uh but for me
i've been watching right now for a lot
of research for something else i'm
producing is top boy
i would love to be in top boy you know
for netflix i think top boy is super
dope
um that's a really interesting tv show
that i'd love to guest are in
um and uh and yeah
yeah at shit's creek as a canadian i
want to get to shit's creek but
they're done so i i think that i've
missed that boat but shit's creek
and top boy are my two choices what
movie or
movies do you think you've seen the most
i've seen free willy
a lot big free willy guy he knows i've
seen that one too many times
love free willy um another move that's a
bit more current is dark knight
i watch that all the time i love heath
ledger's performance in that i've seen
that so many times as a dark knight
with heath ledger in there i yeah
um we could talk about that for a very
long time um when you were
when did you realize that you wanted to
act was it a performance that you saw
was it something on tv do you remember
what that what the spark was
yeah i mean the spark
it's funny because when i was young i
was always performing but i didn't
understand
exactly that i could turn that into a
profession
i think when i first saw myself on tv
and i said wow that's really cool i want
to do that like that's something that i
i want to do i grew up in the disney era
when like disney was really hot so like
the famous jet jackson
with lee thompson young the lately
thompson young
that was a moment where i said you know
i want to do that and then i was a big
fan
of uh the raven show and all that you
know i love sketch comedy so like those
are the shows
during my younger years that got me
really excited
on the television front i went to
theater
and theater got me going that the
production that i loved in theater was
fiddle around the roof
after seeing fiddler on the roof and
music man
it made me say i can do this for real
for real and really wanted to take this
craft seriously
saw on the stage would be fiddler on the
roof and music man and then television
was um
the famous jet jackson all that and
that's so raven and i'm getting like
three of them but they're all like kind
of tied you know
no completely do you feel at this point
in your career
that you have made it as an actor that
you can do this and this is how you're
going to earn your living
or do you still get nervous after every
role like am i going to book the next
thing
uh i don't know if i've like made it
something that's so subjective because i
feel like some
people feel like they're just i know my
homie
a couple of homies who are really
popping you know it's like nah i'm just
a regular guy but for me
i think i'm still you know trucking away
i'm still hustling um
i don't really worry about the next
paycheck to be honest even because i do
have other business ventures
so acting something i love and it's
something that i do
but uh i don't lose sleep over it if i
don't work for the next year or two
you know uh hopefully i do knock on wood
i really lose a sleeve i've got other
things going on in my life that i'll be
financially secure um
completely i actually think i'm going to
address some of that stuff uh
later on as we talk um is there anything
that you collect
anything that i collect um
i collect photos uh
that's a good question because a lot of
people know this but i i i'm a
photographer i shoot 35
i'll shoot everything on film all
manually i've been shooting film for
years
i don't post anything but i collect all
the photos that i've
i've shot over the years on sets and all
the locations that i've been on
so specific to some of the movies that
i've done i have a lot of portraits of a
lot of a-list celebrities in canon
moments
that i collect and i frame and i put
them in my house in my office and i have
like a little book just to kind of
immortalize some of those memories that
i've
i've i've stacked up over time but
photos i'm a big
photo photo like buff you know even jeff
bridges in the work that he's doing
you know i love filming i love
photography
and so i've been doing that for a number
of years i have a ton of cameras
um and i shoot let's just secretly let
people know i don't use it for instagram
like that and maybe i'll do a gallery
one day probably over like a thousand
photos stephen of like
everyone that i've worked with every red
carpet i've been on i just have a little
pocket rocket that i have
which is a quick shooter that i shoot
real quick and then i have my manual
minolta that i've shown 35 mil
you know 135 million and so i just kind
of do that but yeah film
love film man shoot a lot of photography
i'm curious what is that like
at what point during when you're on a
set um
uh let's say city of lives for example
at what point when you're on a set like
that
do you feel comfortable enough to take
out the camera you feel like you need to
wait a few days
or on day one are you like ah [ __ ] it
i'm going to take some pictures
no no i can definitely read the room
stephen so i'm definitely aware
of of of of the environment that i'm in
but i also try to infuse it with the
characters somehow so every character
that i play
you know i try to infuse the fact that
you know he has a passion
or he has an interest of the craft so
you know i always when i build the
worlds that i'm creating and then i'm
playing in i always try to build
extensive back stories um that i can
infuse some of my own personal
attributes that kind of give the
character that that life and that pop so
i usually come in with my camera i
establish it i say hey guys you know i
do this are you cool you're not cool 100
of the time the actors are cool
uh with me shooting in the rest of the
team and crew and then when they call
cut
you know um before i get this usually
shoot when i'm not working i'll come on
set and shoot
uh with an intense scene i usually don't
do that but
it's usually in the pockets in which i
have a bit of free time
is when i do it a lot of dinners i'll do
it at after parties like the rat parties
and um and any gap that we get but
people love getting their photos taken
believe it or not even in character and
stuff they like to like you know as long
as you're like and i'm kind of
just not sneaking around but i'm very
you know
just secretive how i do it so it just
feels like you're not posing for
anything it's just very candid
i i think i've actually jeff bridges
through his publicist whatever i think
i've gotten a book or two of his
of his photos and they're very very cool
and
um i'm sure in like you know decades
from now
uh you'll look back and be very happy
you did this
yeah i hope hopefully hopefully i'll
have a book and you could say it's cool
too man
so this is a softball question about
city of lies
um and it's definitely not difficult to
answer um who do you think killed tupac
who do i think kill tupac i don't know i
actually it's a genuine question i do
not know
i think there are theories i think there
are people
i don't know who killed pop man i i just
don't know
yeah i asked um um brad that and uh
yeah i mean he had theories but it's i
think it's impossible
you know no one no one has come out um
oh yeah
um jumping into city of lies
specifically um
i'm sure when you were doing research to
uh to do this role and
learning everything you could about
christopher wallace and what really went
on
what surprised you during the research
process that you sort of
maybe didn't know the obvious for me is
how young he was
like he died like 24 25 like i think we
forget how young this man was because he
was so mature
and he had built such a legacy as a
short period of time uh even though it's
out there that's public knowledge that
to me was like a reminder you know i'm
still young right i was a younger guy
during those
times and you know that was something
that really stood out to me um the fact
that this man
was so young and he died so young
that is just still like mind-boggling um
but the the thing that really got me
intrigued
was just how corrupt like literally how
corrupt the system was during that time
like how many police officers were
involved
in this this this this operation
you know this operation to try to take
them out you know it was just that was
very surprising to see that you know the
men and women that are
paid and put in positions to serve and
protect were there to take somebody down
a young dude went down to its core it
was a young dude who was a rapper
you know and like that's what it was to
its core and uh that to me was just very
surprising the corruption
in my research because of the role that
i played was specific to the lapd
um david mack and so the the the
corruption was very
very very surprising to me to me it's
really shocking
that it really still hasn't come out how
many people
on the lapd have were working at death
row and the intertwined nature
of these two organizations um and the
film
you know the film tries to bring a shine
a light on what was going on
i agree i agree and that's why i think
this film is so
it's one of the best you know renditions
of the story
because it's the intrinsic value of just
showing you
you know the facts of this is what the
lapd was like
these are the people that were involved
and this is what happened
and i think this is a lens that we've
never seen before
highlighting this story and why for me
personally it got me excited
um to to really immerse myself not only
into the film but reading the book
labyrinth which i have a lot of funny
stories about my
uh getting this role and with brad and
that book and whatever else oh no you
should definitely share
uh yeah so listen i'll start with this
so when i was when i got when i got the
script
um full disclosure honestly when i got
the script i was in a different place as
an actor so when you're coming up you
just kind of take with what comes right
so i'm sorry whatever so i put this
thing on tape
right i obviously immerse myself in my
thing i wish i'd done the research
realizing this was a johnny depp
film after i'd submit my my audition and
i said damn man i wish i did more
research
none the last two weeks three weeks a
month later i got a call saying that
brad berman wanted to meet me
he flew me to los angeles i waited in
the waiting room for about two hours
back at me waiting
right i think was all a part of his
psychological plan i go into this space
i'm starting to do my audition he stops
me halfway through he looks around his
producers and casting directors and he
goes
everybody get out he kicked everybody
out there and was like everybody get out
the room i just want to be here with
shamir alone that's
it so he sits down with me he looks at
me and goes
sure he can handle this i'm like what do
you mean can i handle it no joke like
this is what he said to me can you
handle this
i'm like yeah i can handle it he's like
if i hire you can you go toe-to-toe with
like johnny and forrest and these guys
right i'm like i can do this trust me i
can do this if you hire me brad
you'll never regret it he said all right
and he's how he can get out of here i
didn't get the call for like a month i'm
not going to get the job whatever
and then i got a job i got the job and
at the time when he called me
i had a booking so i had a conflict and
brad found out that i had a conflict
there was a chance that he might
he probably was going to lose me for
this role i'll never forget getting this
calls in calgary
in the mall i don't know why i was in
calgary don't ask brad calls me i was
you know
if you don't fix this problem it was i
think a mustache you needed me to have a
mustache and i was filming something
else i couldn't have the mustache my
manager daniel abrams was trying to work
it out
called the mustache gate he's like i'm
firing you and i'm replacing you asap
i was so scared as a young actor
thinking that oh my goodness i'm about
to lose the biggest opportunity in my
life
nonetheless you know long story long
everything worked out i was able to go
to set
and i remember in pre-production i got a
knock on my trailer and they said hello
mr mr depp
and mr furman would like to meet you i
said oh my gosh about to be johnny depp
this is insane
so i make my way to johnny depp's
trailer brad comes out brad goes yo
johnny this is the kid i was talking
about from canada you got to come meet
him
then johnny depp comes out the trailer
smoking his whatever he's smoking he
goes
hey shame here man so good to meet you
welcome to the family i gave you a big
hug and i promise you stephen
that moment i have butterflies i was
blushing and i do blush cause i'm black
but i do blush
and i had a big moment and it was
amazing and then the rest was history
that's a great story and thank you for
sharing that's great
yeah i can't even imagine what it's like
especially um
listen johnny's a very talented actor
and i can't imagine what it's like
you know meeting him like that knowing
you're gonna share a scene
yeah no it was it was amazing you know
it was a dream come true and
to that to that end i was super scared
and because i was so
scared to the character process you know
i spent two months in compton
you know prior to filming i spent time
with a lot of bloods
a lot of real gangsters i shaved my head
for the role you know i did a lot of
research
i was so immersed in it that i actually
when these guys were asking me where i
was from i was telling i was a futon pa
root like i was given street signs i was
throwing up the signs i was telling that
i was from there because
i tried it once with the guys where you
from i said canada he's like you're from
where they don't got
gangsters in canada what's up man i was
like oh [ __ ] you know i can't be saying
that to people no more
so i locked in completely and i have
friends from that movie to this day brad
was so gracious
and put all the guys that i worked with
20 bloods from compton
all in the movie you put them on the
movie and gave them jobs gave them sag
permits
like just to give them opportunities so
this movie was inclusive on every level
and uh you know i'm indebted to brad for
life
uh jumping into something else uh you're
doing i'm
curious about this you have some sort of
venture fund with your brothers
that tell me about this i was
researching it last night
explain what you're doing and what
you're trying to accomplish
yeah thank you no so in canada we have
the largest
venture fund for bipoc entrepreneurs you
know making us the youngest venture
capitalist
black venture capitalist in the country
and so our youngest brother sheldon
who is the mastermind behind all of it
realized that
you know outside of having a position
in the business and changing lives to
the arts we have to understand financial
literacy economic empowerment and
generational wealth in our community
and through this we said this is
interesting sheldon he wanted to launch
the bay mills investment group and our
first fund is the bengals diversity fund
which is a fund focused on putting
capital into
um by poc-led businesses to help scale
um in the emerging market of canada and
then bringing a return to our
shareholders
and in short what that means is you know
we invest in companies
that you know need capital help build
their businesses
and then uh and then and then we all win
on every side
and it's a hundred million dollar fun
and to give like you know kind of in a
simplistic term it's kind of like shark
tank you know sheldon is a financial
savvy guy
sheldon's very smart we have a great
team of advisors and board of directors
um and it's funny a lot of people in in
hollywood are actually
playing in this arena um from the will
smith's of the world
to ashton kutcher who's very known he
has sound ventures with gaio siri
um it's it's it's a-rod's doing it um
and
it's about having a team of people it's
not a matter of like i'm going to wake
up and do this tomorrow
you really have to have a a passion and
a student awareness to this arena
which i do have and which i love and
before acting i actually was going to go
to school for criminology and minored in
political science and
and and then i went to acting i don't
know why now but
and so through that we're just really
excited man and forbes has done a really
great thing on us
we're about to close our 100 million
dollar fund which we're really excited
about
uh first i'm just going to say congrats
on making that happen because that is
really hard to do and amazing um
i am very curious you're producing and
you came up with this idea for super
high
and i definitely want to know more about
this because you've got andy sandberg
who i love
so tell people what this film is
yeah super high is about three homies
that get super powers
after smoking some weed that has uh some
magical [ __ ] in it
to put it simply as that uh it's a story
that i came up with
many moons ago i actually pitched it to
my brother stefan james who's also an
actor and i said what do you think about
this man i got this idea and i put
together a whole treatment and
everything and he looked at me like
you're crazy but you're on to something
i was so on to something that i was able
to sell this story to new line
i was able to get andy sandberg and the
lonely iron crew to cut only island crew
to come on and be my co-executive
producers
and be a part of it and so now we have
this major feature film
with andy at the helm craig robinson and
common
and it's called super high uh which i'm
excited about and we're currently in
script
um currently putting the script together
i'm on zooms with those guys they're
hilarious
you know i've met andy multiple times
everybody loves andy
you know and so we're working knee deep
and building out this story and it's
just crazy to say that and think that i
thought this thing
and now it's becoming this big motion
picture
at new line that i put together which is
really exciting man
i'm just curious and i don't want you to
reveal too much but
what are can you reveal some of the
powers you get when you smoke weed
in the film you can fly
[Laughter]
you can fly and some of the superpowers
are like funny like some of them are
like
you know like like you know you're
invisible for like 20 minutes and then
you're not invisible anymore like just
stupid [ __ ] you know what i mean
or like stop somebody you know just just
just like
every time you scream you sound like a
giraffe or something like this crazy
[ __ ] you know like think about it like
really expanding and like and really
pushing the envelope
it's definitely a comedy and when you
work with guys like sandberg
the sky is not the limit you know what i
mean yeah is it one of those things with
the weed that
every time you smoke it's the same power
or each time you smoke it can be
something different
every time you smoke it's always
something different and that's what
makes it so interesting
right i can unders yeah yeah this is
right up the lonely islands uh
alley as well um do you envision is the
hope to try to be filming this
um later this year or next year or you
still have to lock the script
uh we still gotta lock the script in um
i'm currently doing that so
i don't this year would probably be
super ambitious but definitely by next
year you know is definitely the goal
goal to do this um you have a besides uh
stowaway you have another netflix
project awake and i'm curious about that
i don't know too much about it
uh what can you say awake is a film
i'm not sure what's on the internet
right now but i i could tell you that
i'm starring in it with
gina rodriguez um and essentially awake
from what i understand the log line says
is it's about a world in which people
can't sleep
and everyone's awake and um
you go on this adventure of trying to
find
the cure for that we filmed that in
toronto last summer
i met gina on that project who's
incredible
and it's another netflix um under the
netflix umbrella
and i play a very different character
and yeah man
it's a cool little story so we'll see
what happens with that and when it comes
out
i was going to say you have a few things
with netflix right now which is nice
yes and i do i do have another one
called bruised with halle berry which is
her directoral debut
um where she plays an mma fighter uh
making a comeback
and that one premiered at tiff last year
uh during the pandemics unfortunately
none of the cast was there but i was
able to facetime halle berry
and uh show her to the entire audience
which is really cool
but i'm excited to be a part of that
film that was a lot of fun you know
working with halle berry in her doctoral
debut and spending a lot of time with
her
super sweet super genuine and a real
real athlete of a woman like that woman
like
killer like doing stuff i couldn't do i
know that what she did in john wick
three
uh was her she trained for a long time
if you don't know you should uh
find out all the stuff she did to work
with the dogs
because she was the trainer on set with
the dogs
as it's like a whole thing that i
learned what she did it was
amazing she's a titan like she's a titan
like stephen like she'll outrun you or
not she'll put both of us in guillotines
at the same time
and make us tap out without question
halle bear will make us tap out
oh i can't even imagine for you uh
because obviously you you grew up
watching her
that must have been one of those shoots
where you're when you're filming that
literally every friend you have is like
can i visit you on set today yes
it was not only that not only do they
want to visit me on set like hallie is
like
such a human and i mean that because
people on the outside are like okay
iconic legendary they put her in this
like esoteric space but
when she texts me all the time i still
get a little bit like i'm like oh man
texting me right now this is crazy you
know my managers and agents are still
like you know
all the dudes are like hey man talking
to hallie but hallie is super super dope
but yes i still blush
every time hallie calls my phone every
time without question
i i can only imagine my last thing for
you as i said could uh we're about out
of time
uh i think it's really cool what you're
doing with this black academy
in canada trying to take on systemic
racism
yeah um and so can you talk a little bit
about what you're trying to accomplish
with that
yeah thank you man so unlike the venture
fund which is very financial focused in
the financial sector our black academy
is arts focus this is something that
stephanie and i are passionate about we
founded uh black which is an acronym for
building a legacy
enacting cinema and knowledge six years
ago and it was a party during the
toronto international film festival six
years later we're now an official
not-for-profit
where we have programs we have mentored
the next emerging
talent out of canada who are black and
by poc
and the black academy uh we formed this
year and
in tandem with the black academy we're
launching the first ever
black award show telecast in the country
similar to the grammys or naacp awards
of the oscars
we founded this award show that's going
to be honoring celebrating and
uplift you know lifting black talent you
know who are canadian
um it's very rare that you're able to
see black canadians
in the spaces you know um in this
business at the highest level similar to
denzel washington of the world and
you know the viola davis um and so
we wanted to do that at home we believe
that if you can see it you can believe
it and this is why we started the black
academy
which we're so excited about and it's
been getting a lot of traction
and in 2022 is when the award show was
gonna launch
uh amazing congratulations
i feel like after talking to you um
that i even though i work really hard i
feel like i'm very lazy
um because you've managed to accomplish
so much
in a short period of time i guess my
last thing for you is do you sleep
um what yeah man i do i do sleep it's
it's a lot of scheduling and a lot of
stress i'm very
structured in my life and so i do i do
sleep i do sleep is very important so
that's a good question but i do sleep
yes i do i also don't drink and also
don't party but i do sleep and so i
think it kind of balances it out uh
yes i will say that i'm glad you don't
drink but i do enjoy red wine red wine
is quite good
nothing's nothing's wrong with drinking
you know what i mean nothing is wrong
with drinking and i will say i do dabble
when like we're celebrating something
cool
for sure but you know i just i'm such a
sucker i'm a lightweight so if i get
drunk i'm passing out i'm not gonna pass
out drunk as soon as i take a shot
i'm like on my bed sleeping like a baby
so that's the only reason i don't drink
because it takes away from my work
productivity
you have to go but um i totally uh um
yeah i'm not one of those people or even
when the pandemic wasn't on um
you can waste a lot of time just going
out and celebrating
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but all good
man you got to you know you got it to
balance you know what i'm saying so
no it's it's it's uh it's cool i do
sleep and i do have a great team that
helps me you know
do what i need to do so i'm grateful
it's a good balance i got a good balance
man
on that note i think you have something
else at 9 30 so i'm going to leave you b
and say uh great talking with you again
and
uh wish you nothing but the best i
appreciate you stephen good talking to
you too